ياناصيب بلغت قيمتها رقما قياسيا
عالميا هو ملياران واربعون مليون
التخلي عن احد عشر الف موظف. فهل
افلست ميتا? لا يا صديقي لم
العالمية. فهل نفذ صبرك يا
ماكرون? امريكي يفوز بجائزة
ويليام سن في حكومته بعد اتهامات
اليه بالتنمر. فيسبوك تنوي
بعض الانتقادات التي وجهت لقطر
لها اهداف سياسية وعنصرية. اول
الغيث قطرة سوناك يعلن قبول
استقالة اول وزير وهو جافن
الحدود العراقية السورية غربي
العراق فهل عاد العراق لجراحه?
في تجمع الاحداث والتطورات. وزير
الدفاع الفرنسي يعترف بعدم قدرة
جيش بلاده على خوض عمليات عسكرية
كبيرة. مصادر امنية عراقية
طائرات مروحية واخرى شنت غارات
على رتل لصهاريج لنقل النفط على
سلفه ترامب ليرد ترامب ويتهم
ادارة بايدن بالفشل ويقول انها
يتهم بايدن وحلفاؤه روسيا انها
تريد بالديمقراطيين من الكونجرس
جارته الجنوبية اصبح من ضمن
قائمة اعدائه. معركة الصناديق.
اشبه بالوصفة الطبية صاروخان في
الصباح وصاروخ اخر بعد لوجبة.
تكتفي بذلك. حيث اعلنت جارتها
الجنوبية ان بيونج يانج اطلقت
اشعلت غضب بكين على الجزيرة
التايوانية نانسي بيلوسي تعتزم
فاصحاب العيون الضيقة يدرسون كل
شيء بدقة. وهنا الباسوس التي
للمقاتلين الاوكرانيين فالحرب كر
وفر. حيث ان هذا النوع الدبابات
الغرب? نعم دبابة الاختراق
الروسية تصبح صيدا ثمينا
قطر للمونديال بانها كانت خطأ
وحمل نفسه مسؤولية ذلك القرار
بعدم التخلي عن سنتيمتر واحد
لروسيا في شرق اوكرانيا. وهنا
لسخائكم ايها الاوروبيون. لتراهن
موسكو على كتيبة الصومال
الكرم الاوروبي من جهة اخرى.
ووزير المالية التشيكي يصرح ان
خرج الرئيس الشيشاني قديروف
مؤيدا اعادة الانتشار على ضفاف
دولار والمفاجأة هنا لقد اشتراها
من لاجئ سوري. يا لحظك تعيس يا
ليصله الرد من الرئيس التنفيذي
لكأس العالم في قطر ناصر الخاطر
هناك كمين بانتظارنا. ومسؤول
عسكري امريكي يطالب بسرعة
المفاوضات السرية الى ساحة الحرب
العالمي. معارك شرسة في خرسون
وما حولها والدفاع الروسية تعلن
صد الهجمات الاوكرانية وتكبيد
عن امله في ان يقبل نظيره الروسي
بوتين بحث تبادل السجناء بعد
اين انت ايها السوداني الرئيس
السابق جوزيف بلاتر يصف استضافة
ترامب قبل الانتخابات قد استعرض
هفوات وزلات بايدن على شاشة ضخمة
هواتف جالكسي. ومع تهديد هذا
الصاروخ تعود موسكو لتعلن
حولت البلاد الى دولة بوليسية
وحرب الصناديق تشتعل. بينما كان
والسعودية تستفز المجنون لينفس
عن غضبه باطلاق صواريخ جديدة
التفاوض مع روسيا تقبل ولكن في
ساحة عربية فما هي هذه الدولة
ووفقا لما صرح به الرئيس الروسي
فان هذا الصاروخ الثقيل العابر
باليستي لا يمكن نعم انهم
يتحدثون عن الصاروخ الروسي
الشطرنج. ها هي روسيا تتلاعب
باعصاب الغرب وكانها تلعب الحرب
على الارض. فاي طريق سيختار
الروس والاوكران يا ترى? صحيح.
الانتخابات مزورة. نعم هكذا شجع
ترامب انصاره بهذا المبدأ بينما
الوضع في شبه الجزيرة الكورية
العاصمة الكورية الشمالية لم
الديموقراطي ليعلنها دونالد
ترامب اما ان نفوز واما ان تكون
معركة حامية الوطيس انطلقت بين
حزب ترامب الجمهوري وحزب بايدن
هذا. الشيطان الاكبر يعود للظهور
والمفاوضات تقترب. والمعارك تشتد
محمد بن سلمان يوم السابع عشر من
نوفمبر في مكتبه في يونج سان
لمكافحة التضخم. اعتبر انه لا
يتماشى مع قواعد منظمة التجارة
يفعلها. القوات الروسية تنسحب
بامر من بوتين وزل نسكي قد يكون
بسيول. فكيف سيرد المجنون على بن
سلمان يا ترى? فكل من دخل الى
المتوقع ان يلتقي الرئيس يونسيو
كيول بولي العهد السعودي الامير
تفلس. فحسابي تم حظره. واستجاب
الله لدعوتي. الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون ينتقد القانون
الصادر في الولايات المتحدة
المدفعية في الوقت الذي تموه فيه
بيونج يانج بارسالها شحنات
ويقول ان كوريا الشمالية تزود
روسيا سرا بعدد كبير من القذائف
في اوكرانيا. وبحسب الصحيفة
البريطانية فقد قام الجيش الروسي
زيارة ولي العهد السعودي لسيول.
وذكرت وكالة يونهاب انه من
صاروخا باليستيا باتجاه بحر
اليابان. لقد اصبحت صواريخ كيم
فهل هذا هو دواءهم يا كيم? وبين
هذا وذاك كوريا الجنوبية تعلن عن
المتحدة وتقول ان السلوك المتحيز
لجوتيريش والمسؤول عن خطورة
الاكثر تطورا في العالم كشفت
نقطة ضعف كوريا الشمالية بسبب
هل يستورد المجنون اسلحته ام انه
من يصدر الاسلحة? ما هذا
الامريكي. وهنا خرج بايدن قائلا
انه ورث فوضى عارمة من ادارة
الكتيبة بهذا الاسم الى هيئة
المقاتلين واشكالهم فهي تشبه لحد
لقد انتهت مهمتي هنا. بيونج يانج
تربك الغرب. بعد ان اتهموه
بالقاء هؤلاء المجندين البالغ
عددهم واحدا وعشرين مجندا في قبو
اوكرانيا الى الغنائم غنيمة
ثمينة تقع هذه المرة في ايادي
الاسلحة الى دول افريقيا لقد
اختلط الامر علينا ايها الغربي.
بصواريخه الباليستية. اليوم هم
يقولون ان مقاتلات عاصفة اليقظة
بالضعف واثاروا غضبه. واستثاروا
شهيته لرائحة البارود ليمطرهم
التناقض? لتخرج بيونج يانج او
تنتقد الامين العام للامم
برأيكم هل هذه الاخبار صحيحة? ام
انها دراما اعلامية جديدة? بكين
التنحي عن رئاسة مجلس النواب
الامريكي بعد تسعة عشر عاما
ازمة سلاح الجوف بلاد المجنون
ليظهر السكرتير الصحفي للبنتاجون
كقائدة للديمقراطيين في مجلس
نواب وكانها تقول للصين باي باي
يعود هنا ليؤكد ان اوكرانيا حذرة
من اي وقوع خاطئ في احدى فخاخ
العسكري التام. فكم تحتاج من
الوقت لحرب كهذه يا شيجن بينغ
نار دينيبرو ومؤكدا ان ذلك جاء
لحفظ ارواح الجنود. لكن زينسكي
العسكرية الموالية لها في شرق
اوكرانيا حيث تعود تسمية هذه
كتيبة حركة شباب الصومال بالشكل
واللباس مع اختلاف طفيف بلون
تحت الارض مشيرة الى انهم مهددون
بالاعدام الجماعي رميا بالرصاص.
واوكرانيا بسرعة التفاوض مع
روسيا قبل فوات الاوان. نتائج
هي اخر ما توصلت اليه
التكنولوجيا العسكرية الروسية من
وفي حدث نادر الرئيس الصيني
البزة العسكرية ويدعو للاستعداد
حيث التحصين والقوة الضاربة.
بينما نشرت صحيفة ديلي ميل
حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا? وها هي
بكين تطبخ حربها على نار هادئة?
تحارب بصمت. حروب الصين ليست
كغيرها? وبكين اخذت العبرة من
البريطانية صورا لمجموعة من
المجندين الروس الرافضين للقتال
اكثر من مائة الف جندي روسي حتى
الان. وربما العدد نفسه في
البشر فهل ينجح رهان الروس على
هذه الكتيبة? ومن قوات الحرب في
بوتين. وذلك بعد اعلان روسيا سحب
قواتها من خرسون دون بينما ينهال
الانتخابات فهل سينجح العجوز
الامريكي في اقناع بوتين? ومن
الجانب الاوكراني فيما طالب
مسؤول عسكري امريكي اخر روسيا
معركة خيرسون ظهرت عندما اعلنت
روسيا انسحابها من المنطقة بما
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيقدم ثمانية
عشر مليار يورو لاوكرانيا. فيا
رويترز تنقل عن جنرال امريكي بان
التقديرات تفيد بمقتل واصابة
وستين عسكريا اوكرانيا في محور
ليخرج الرئيس الاوكراني ويتعهد
قوات كييف خسائر كبيرة كما اعلنت
الوزارة الروسية قضاءها على مائة
النووية بين البلدين والذي
انسحبت منه روسيا مؤخرا. وكالة
ليحل بها هذا اللقاء. الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن. اعرب بدوره
بلومبرج الامريكية تقول ان
القاهرة قد تكون مكانا مناسبا
وامريكا على طاولة واحدة والهدف
نقاش استئناف عمليات التفتيش
للصواريخ لقد اصبحت اصدارات
الاسلحة الروسية تسابق اصدارات
بموجب معاهدة نيو ستارت وهو
الاتفاق الرئيسي لنزع الاسلحة
اوزارها? التقارير الغربية تتحدث
عن لقاء مرتقب يجمع روسيا
استعدادها للمفاوضات مع كييف دون
شروط مسبقة فهل تضع الحرب
الجديد بحلول نهاية هذا العام
وفق ما ذكرت صحيفة ديلي ميل.
سارمات المعروف باسم الشيطان
اثنين المؤلف من اربعة عشر طابقا
على رقعة شطرنج ليخرج الغربيون
اليوم قائلين نحن نتحدث عن صاروخ
والقادر على ازالة مدن باكملها
حيث تعتزم موسكو اختبار سلاحها
للقارات قادر على التفوق على
الانظمة الحديثة المضادة
مجددا فكيف سترد الحكومة
العراقية? روسيا والغرب على رقعة
فهل يعود الرجل الاصفر الى قيادة
امريكا من جديد وفرنسا تبدأ
بالحرب الباردة ضد الولايات
المتحدة والعراق يستقبل الضربات
تجاه اليابان وترامب اما ان نفوز
واما ان تكون الانتخابات مزورة.
والرئيس الصيني يلبس بزته
العسكرية ويأمر جيشه بالتأهب
الغرب في اوكرانيا ووزير الدفاع
الفرنسي جيشنا لا يستطيع ان